you mentioned Portlandia yeah
um was it a daunting idea to go from SNL
to I mean you started Portlandia while
you were still honest I was still there
and uh but to go do your own sketch
comedy it was low pressure as well oh
really because it was uh IFC it was like
a little channel that so it was a little
bit like having uh a sort of
uh YouTube show or something it's
equivalent of that yeah
um and then also that it was with Carrie
yeah so
um because she's my old friend it felt
like oh let's just do this for fun and
we'll get to hang out in Portland all
summer yeah so it uh it didn't have it
wasn't like leaving SNL and now I have
to do another NBC show it wasn't that
that's like pressure was she already
living there oh yeah yeah
still does did you have to convince her
to
that you know to do a comedy show or was
she the um the project itself was both
of us oh I see
um I was friends with her and uh as I
got to know her we're like we should
work on something together and then the
idea of a band just seems so
cliche and like yeah we put out a record
and you know it's just something about
it was like not interesting for either
of us yeah
but we thought like what about Portland
because that's where I would visit her
yeah what can we do with being here
and then it just we started doing the
feminist bookstore and a couple other
sketches and then that it immediately
we're like this is something we can do
yeah yeah and also
I mean that town is a really beautiful
fun yeah awesome town but also really
ripe for yeah getting having a little
bit of the air taken out of it you know
and it was like it was also my
experience in different even in parts of
LA yeah and then Silver Lake sure or
Brooklyn and sure this thing was
happening it's an episode but that's an
episode that's where like it it was um
devoid of other cities around it yeah
because you know Brooklyn had Manhattan
but there's something about Portland
that was very sort of like an island of
of that yeah
um and
it's also the way we we were living I
was attracted to that stuff anyway yeah
yeah those cool bookstores and stuff how
much of it was I mean was there some of
the stuff that you kind of poked fun at
about it that had a real kind of like oh
come on as opposed to like I love this
and it could take some gentle prodding I
mean was there some of it that was
really
Oh you mean like reactions from other
people no no I mean you're you're
feeling about you know like like
pickling things yeah yeah like were you
really like it's fun that people are
pickling things or was there an aspect
of come on enough with the pickling no
it was more like in the writer's room
uh-huh uh anything that resonated you're
like oh what can we do um I just feel
like I'm seeing pickling a lot like
that's just jars of it and artisanal
pickles so let's just write the sketch
yeah um the very first sketch was put a
bird on it yeah and that was Carrie's
idea where she's like I noticed that any
you know shop even like chain stores
will have something with a bird on it to
make it look a little more
you know Retro Retro yeah and um and so
anything that resonated so it was less
of oh we're sick of this and more like
oh I think that is something that's
happening yeah that's a better way to do
it too because it is it's not
I mean my the way I suggested is like
it's already kind of dead you're already
kind of looking back on something that's
that's kind of grown Beyond its yes you
know it's necessary size like um Target
is a good place to see like you'll see
things in Target
that's when you know it sort of jumped
over to like those light bulbs you know
they're very like you know those new
artisanal light bulbs you see where you
set up tons of yeah yeah yeah
yeah those light bulbs yeah